in Washington the house select committee
investigating the assault on the capitol
has postponed what had been today's
planned public hearing due to Hurricane
Ian but a writer who confessed to one of
the most violent attacks on January 6 is
headed to prison for a good long time
Scott McFarland is on Capitol Hill
following all of this for us Scott the
judge said from the bench that this was
a one-man wrecking ball good morning
Good morning Tony and this is one of the
longest prison sentences handed down in
any January 6 case so far Kyle young of
Iowa will spend more than seven years in
prison for his role in the attack on
injured D.C police officer Michael
fanone fanone's body camera footage
showing the brutal assault was a key
part of this case and Fanon testified at
sentencing yesterday arguing January 6th
helped end his career federal judge Amy
Berman Jackson in issuing the sentence
described Kyle Young's actions that day
as some of the darkest acts committed on
one of America's Darkest Days meanwhile
jury selection resumes this morning in
one of the highest profile Capital Riot
cases five accused Oath Keepers
including Founders Stuart Rhodes they're
charged with seditious conspiracy
accused of plotting to block the
peaceful transfer of power of staging
guns outside the city limits and of
directing a military stack formation to
breach the police line that day they
pleaded not guilty today's January 6
Committee hearing was expected to focus
on The Oath Keepers and any connection
they may have had to former Trump Ally
Roger Stone the committee will
reschedule that hearing postponed due to
the hurricane and we'll have to do so by
the end of the year Gail
all right we're all still watching after
looking at the video it's so hard that
anybody could ever characterize that as
no big deal just Patriots hanging out
thank you very much Scott